[Musique]
accorde à pompe ou à manivelle
aujourd'hui on lave notre laitue avec
les samedis et rebecca hall
les propriétaires des populaires
restaurants wendy's test avec nous
invité sur eux elles vont mesurer leurs
capacités d'essorage leur ergonomie leur
design mais d'abord leur mécanisme ne
serait pas seul à monter
ça marche
ça c'est celui là et il est plus facile
de mobiliser
excellent et ali a pas un frein côté des
années esthétique les wolf préfère la
simplicité
j'aime beaucoup le look de celui là je
trouve que c'est très clean c'est parce
que c'est transparent on peut voir que
ce qui se passe ça j'adore ce village et
ses tubes blanc pour moi c'est mon
préfère celui très facile est ce que
vous trouvez qu'il est assez dur ans
celui-là passé quoi moi même si c'est
juste une salade pour moi et mon mari
la sallaz les plus grands catcheurs le
lavage une entretien simplifié est aussi
un critère je pouvais voir tous les
endroits comme celui là
et j'ai trouvé avec une corde sais pas
c'est pas assez ironique pour le large
et avec un corps d'après des années je
trouve que les imports façon de les
laver facilement c'est comment tu es
prêt dans un restaurant de salades mais
ce qu'on veut vraiment vérifié c'est
leur capacité des sauvages nous avons
tremper les laitues dans la même
quantité d'eau nous avons ensuite
activer les mécanismes pendant deux
cycles de 15 secondes ça se passe bien
vous pouvez comme le tenir
non
même si presque toutes les épreuves
fonctionne aisément les soeurs ont
particulièrement apprécié libre de la
peau je trouve qu'avec une pompe c'est
aussi plus facile ça reste dans nos
dates sécuritaire il faut pas vraiment
comme utiliser l'autre main pour le
stabiliser
seuls deux modèles kitchenaid semblait
plus difficile à manipuler
je trouve que beaucoup de résistance à
noter aussi qu'après une seule
utilisation
le piston de ce modèle refusait de se
contracter sont tous comme
sept des huit et heureuse ont réussi à
retirer la même quantité d'eau soit 60
min litres par contre les heureuses de
trudeau avec son système de rotation
fixe n'a pas impressionné c'est presque
la moitié ce modèle n'a retiré que 30
millilitres pour savoir si sa basse
vitesse de rotation pouvait expliquer sa
piètre performance
nous avons consulté un professeur en
génie physique à l'aide de stroboscopes
nous avons évalué les vitesses de
rotation de toutes les erreurs on l'a
pas mal
la vitesse de rotation des assureurs en
fait en terme de rotations par minute va
de quelques centaines à proche d'un
millier de rotations par minute
ça crée des accélérations qui sont de
l'ordre de plusieurs fois celle de la
gravité sur terre est un peu comme dans
un manège d'un rotor par exemple parce
qu'on est plaqué contre le mur aussi
quand des très très grande accélération
à 800 toutes les haies se retourner plus
de 600 tours minute
sauf les trudeau que nous avons mesuré à
300 tours minute
mais la vitesse n'explique pas tout
pense par exemple à la taille des trous
ci avait pas de trou dans mon bassin
malausse évacuerait pas donc
multimania plein plein de choses à
considérer pour faire attention c'est
pas que la vitesse n'est pas parce que
c'est plus vite que nécessairement ça va
être meilleur honnêtement à toutes fins
c'est vraiment une question de celles
qu'on trouve la plus belle la plus
pratique la plus durable qui a séduit
notre carte qui va l'emporter
côté pratique 3d modèles prétendent
pouvoir restaurer des fruits dont le
modèle kitchenaid avec ses compartiments
séparés
le vagabond le fruit sont vraiment
[Musique]
ç'a été facile mais qu'il y avait des
femmes des fonctionne pour les fruits
pour laver les fruits pour moi c'était
la première fois que j'ai vu ça je
trouve que c'est extra éléments qui est
très intéressant après tout ces essais
lisseur wulff ont arrêté leur choix sur
les sauteuses oxo c'était vraiment
facile à porter
aucun effort public c'est dans la
cuisine ça va être très bien
[Musique]